>> Tucker: IT WOULD BE NICE TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
DAN BONGINO, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
JIM GARD IS A MATH TEACHER AT
THE SCHOOL AND HE TAUGHT THE
SUSPECT LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> HI, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> Tucker: WELL, YOU ARE THE
FIRST PERSON WE HAVE SPOKEN TO
THAT NEW THE SUSPECT PERSONALLY
IN YOUR CLASS.
WHAT WAS YOUR VIEW OF HIM?
>> I ONLY HAD HIM FOR A SEMESTER
BETWEEN AUGUST AND DECEMBER OF
2016, FROM WHAT I CAN REMEMBER.
I'M JUST LOOKING AT MY COMPUTER,
I WILL HAVE TO LOOK A LITTLE BIT
LATER TO BE 100% SURE.
HE WAS REALLY QUIET, NOTHING
OUTSTANDING.
A COUPLE OF EMAILS FROM ADMINS
REGARDING HIM, BUT I CAN GET
INTO MY COMPUTER AND SEE IF THEY
HAD ANYTHING HIGHLIGHTED THAT I
CAN REMEMBER.
>> Tucker: LET ME PUT IT THIS
WAY, WHEN HE SAW HIS FACE ON
TELEVISION AND READ HIS NAME,
DID YOU THINK, I AM SHOCKED BY
THIS?
OR DID YOU THINK OF THE KIDS
THAT I TEACH, MAYBE THIS IS NOT
THE MOST SURPRISING SUSPECT?
>> I DID NOT SEE HIS FACE ON
TELEVISION YET, WE WERE IN
LOCKDOWN WITH NO TVs ON.
I HEARD THE NAME FROM SOME OF MY
STUDENTS WHEN WE WERE IN THE
LOCKDOWN.
AND I WAS LIKE, OH, WOW, I HAD
HIM IN CLASS.
AND THEN THE POLICE CAME AND GOT
US OUT OF OUR ROOM.
SO IN MY SHOCK, I HATE TO SAY
IT, NOWADAYS WITH ALL OF THE
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS, NOTHING IS